Speaker 1: Well, everybody, they they pass
something, they they did pass something, and we're
going to talk about what that something is. After
months of negotiations, as some have called them,
the House on Friday passed a much smaller $1.2
trillion bipartisan infrastructure bill. Not every
Democrat voted for it. And some Republicans voted
for it. Those Republicans are now being told they
are going to be removed by other Republicans, but
we're going to get to that. It does finally give
Joe Biden something that can be called a win.
It's a much smaller win than I hoped for for
the good of the country. It's a much smaller
win than Democrats most of them hoped for
from the standpoint of politics, but it did
pass the House 228 to two zero six, and this is
mostly a bill with what Republicans would call
real infrastructure spending. Now we don't
really go by calling things what Republicans call
them, because if we did, we'd be very stupid. But
what others refer to to this type of spending as
is hard infrastructure, big investments in roads,
bridges, waterways and other things that we're
going to talk about, some that I'm pleased to see,
to be perfectly frank. 13 Republicans voted in
favor of this bill. Six Democrats voted against
this bill. The 13 Republicans voting in favor,
mostly the folks we aren't surprised to hear,
would cross party lines to vote in favor, the
Democrats voting against supposed progressives
as they are often described. And you know, we
can talk later about whether we're surprised that
they voted against it or not. Nancy Pelosi was
negotiating. Biden was helping try to get it done.
And finally, on Friday, they got the vote. Now
the House goes to a recess, then they're going
to take up the social spending bill, also known
by some as build back better, many saying that's
dead. Others saying, No sir, it might pass. What
some have said they want before they will consider
the build back better bill is a score from the
CBO as to the total cost and economic impact of
the social spending bill. Slash build back
better bill. So this is not that this is the
infrastructure bill. Now again, remember this is
if you already were ashamed at the size of this
package, OK, because it's $1.2 trillion instead of
two three trillion, it's number one $1.2 trillion
over eight years and only five hundred and
fifty billion of the 1.2 trillion is new
spending. The rest is to fund existing programs.
So what we're talking about here is a package
that is $69 billion per year in new spending for
an economy the size of the United States economy.
This is not a massive package at all. We're not
talking about an amount of spending that should
be this difficult to get done now. What is in
the bill specifically? Well, let's look at it.
One hundred and ten billion for roads, bridges,
infrastructure, fix ups across the country. All
right. Seventy three billion for electric
grid and power structures. Even that some
Republicans are saying, that's not really what
we should be doing in infrastructure spending.
Hint it is sixty six billion for rail services.
We have some of the most pathetic rail in the rich
developed world. 65 billion for broadband.
We have pathetic broadband access in the US,
55 billion for water or water. As some say.
That's again, we they're still part. Can
they even drink water in Michigan out of the tap
yet in Flint, Michigan? I don't think they can.
21 billion for environmental remediation.
47 billion for flooding. Coastal and climate
resiliency very much needed as we deal with
sea level rise 39 billion to modernize transit,
25 billion for airports. Our airports,
many of them are pathetic 17 billion for
port infrastructure. Remember, they're mad. We
don't have more room at ports to get the Chinese
tchotchkes in for Christmas. But they also don't
want to spend on ports. Well, this bill would
do some of that 11 billion in transportation
safety programs. Seven point five billion for
electric vehicles and charging. I would
honestly like to see that much higher.
I would also have loved to have seen spending
on retrofitting for retrofitting homes to be
completely electric. But when you go
electric, you can't have that inefficient
electric baseboard heating. We want to go with the
super efficient heat pumps and mini split systems
and then solar. You can go house by house. Listen
to a very interesting podcast about this recently.
You put solar panels on the roof. You
get all of. The oil and gas heat out.
You get the inefficient window sees outright,
I mean, you go to fully electric but efficient
electric, we'd like to see more on that. OK?
Two point five billion in zero emission busses,
2.5 billion in low emission busses and 2.5
billion for ferries. Now, you might notice nothing
for sinks and showers, which Donald Trump was
obsessed with nothing for toilets. It seems we're
not really having to flush toilets 10 to 15 times
under Joe Biden, as Donald Trump predicted. But a
lot of good things being done now. If you add that
all up, it's five hundred and forty four billion.
I called it roughly five fifty. What's the rest
you might be saying? It's a $1.2 trillion package.
David, you only read 550 worth of spending. Well,
it's programs already in existence. And again, the
fact that there's this much arguing over a bill
that as it's left, mostly funds existing programs,
it is globally humiliating. So politically, Biden
needed something. This is something it's not great
without it. It's a political disaster for
Joe Biden. And with it, there's still more
stuff to get done. But it's at least something to
justify another three months in the Oval Office,
right? It keeps you treading water. You've not
drowned, but you're not safe on shore, either. It
keeps you treading. Water is sort of the way that
I would describe it. So that's what's in the bill.
That's what passed so far. We now have to talk
about instantly the Civil War, Republicans again
coming for their own, saying those 13 Republicans
who voted for this, we got to remove those people.